We Begin this hour with breaking news
Armenian State television says that a
ceasefire has been agreed between
azerbaijani and ethnic Armenian forces
after intense fighting in
nagorno-karabakh on Tuesday Baku
launched artillery strikes on the
Region's Capital at least 32 people are
reported to have been killed more than
200 injured now the two sides have been
locked in a dispute for decades over
nagorno-karabakh most recently leading
to a war in 2020 Dimitri medvedenko
takes a look now at the events of the
past 48 hours
on the streets of stepanakert the main
city in nagora karabakh
Panic took over as mortars pounded its
surroundings
this ethnic Armenian dominated enclave
and self-declared Breakaway territory is
internationally recognized as part of
Azerbaijan but it is controlled by
ethnic Armenians and has close links to
The Armenian government it is the source
of instability and tension between the
two countries
and the threat of out and out conflict
is never far away
both have gone to war over the region in
the early 1990s after the fall of the
Soviet Union and in 2020 which ended
after a ceasefire agreement
the latest source of tension as the
continuing blockade by azeri forces of
the Latin Corridor an area of land
linking Armenia to nagorna karabakh a
separate Corridor known as agdam Road
connects the rest of Azerbaijan with The
Enclave Baku says authorities there have
refused to accept supplies from that
corridor
Russia one of the backers of the
ceasefire has urged the two countries to
stop the fighting
Russia strongly encourages the
conflicting sides to stop the Bloodshed
stop the military actions at once and
return to a political and diplomatic
settlement
Outside The Armenian parliament in
Yerevan crowds gathered to protest
against the renewed military operations
urging the government to do more to
protect the people of nagorna karabakh
as once again the tension between the
two countries spills over into conflict
Dimitri met vedenko Al Jazeera
well meanwhile Moscow says that Russian
peacekeepers have evacuated more than 2
000 civilians from nagorno-karabakh
Russia's defense Ministry says it's
provided temporary shelters for ethnic
Armenians from that region as well as
Medical Aid Moscow says its troops
continue their peacekeeping mission
there well let's bring in Julia
chapovalova she joins us now from Moscow
Yulia now that we've heard that the
ceasefire has been announced Moscow must
be pretty happy about that
okay
well we all hope that nagorna karabakh
war number three has been avoided we're
hoping that there are high hopes that
nothing awful will happen uh seems like
the official Russia has taken sides with
Azerbaijan and its closest Allied turkey
this time around the Russian president
has was meeting the Turkish leader just
recently in sanctuary where the sides
were discussing the economy and mutual
trade as well as politics both are very
much dependent on each other but but
despite that many Russian people a lot
of them are very sympathetic towards the
Armenians in karabakha there is now a
humanitarian crisis in the region in
December 2022 we know that Azerbaijan
blocks the illusion Corridor the only
Road connecting karabakh with Armenia
and since then they've been a shortage
of food and Medicine in the region and
basically what we hear now the message
is that
probably should be heard during the U.N
general assembly is that no military
aggression is Justified in the 21st
century even to achieve the highest
goals because always innocent civilians
children and the elderly suffer from the
hostilities and their lives simply get
ruined
well as we know Russia has had
peacekeepers there in the region and has
obviously been very heavily involved in
mediation talk us through their role now
so basically as you said the Russian
peacekeeping contingent has evacuated
more than a 2 000 civilians over half of
them children from all the dangerous
areas of nagorna karabakh the Russian
defense Ministry
was reporting that and actually they
said that doctors from the specialized
medical units had given Aid to the
wounded so the Russian peacekeepers
mission is to protect locals and help
evacuate them and not to intervene in
the military actions that's according to
the Russian side we've heard from some
Russian officials saying that the
Russian peacekeepers can't start
shooting unless their lives are in
danger so basically they're there to
help and the Russian Ministry of defense
is actually reporting about their
actions now in the area
there with the latest for us from Moscow
thank you Julia